Hi I’m John Green and this is Crash Course
European History.
So, remember back in May of 1453 when the
Ottomans smashed the thick walls of Constantinople,
captured the city, and beheaded the Byzantine
emperor?
You probably don’t remember May of 1453,
come to think of it, but you remember learning
about it.
It was a bit of a footnote in our first episode,
but you never know when the footnotes are
going to be very important, but that one really
did change the world.
With the Ottomans now also controlling much
of southeastern Europe, they established a
navy, which they used in the Black, Adriatic,
and other seas in the region.
Ottoman domination meant that European kingdoms
and empires needed to find different paths
to Afroeurasian trading routes--which ultimately
helped spark the voyages of explorers from
the Iberian peninsula.
INTRO
So we’ve talked already in this series about
the importance of shifting perspective when
looking at history, and today we’re going
to ask you to shift perspective several times,
but let’s begin with the perspective of
the Portuguese.
In the fifteenth century, Portugal was poor,
and it became more so as the Ottomans contested
their access to overland trade.
But luckily for Portugal, the fourth son of
their king was Prince Henry, who came to be
called The Navigator because he funded and
encouraged exploration, the study of navigation,
and the development of new tools to aid in
navigation.
The Portuguese began to increase their travels
along the Mediterranean’s southern shore.
And by the mid-15th century, they were venturing
southward along the Atlantic coast of Africa,
where they expected to find vast wealth.
In those days, Africa was rich in food, salt,
gold, and slaves.
Mansa Musa, the Malian king who made a spectacular
hajj to Mecca in 1324-1325, was legendary
and very inspiring to the Portuguese.
He had an entourage of 60,000 people including
12,000 slaves and huge quantities of gold.
He seemed like the model of what the Portuguese
hoped to become by traveling to Africa: that
is, rich beyond imagining.
In this pursuit of food, slaves, and gold,
the Portuguese gradually made their way down
the African coast, locating island clusters
like the Canaries.
And they kidnapped local people to sell into
European slave markets and began dotting the
coast with stone fortresses that doubled as
trading stations.
And there, many European men partnered with
African women and started families.
These women were often themselves traders
and would be crucial for all European nations;
because they were the main force behind local
markets and regional trade networks, and they
provided essential connections to trade.
Again, most of the Portuguese explorers were
poor, and many of these female traders were
wealthy and successful.
From their perspective, Portuguese traders
offered them access to new markets and access
to new goods.
I know we’re all very accustomed to thinking
of Europe as rich and Africa as poor, but
that frame is both relatively new and way
too essentializing--the truth as always resists
simplicity.
So in 1488, Bartolomeu Dias rounded the Cape
of Good Hope, or, as it was called at the
time, the Cape of Storms.
And then the Portuguese ventured further afield
into the Indian Ocean.
When we talk about explorers and exploring,
we often conjure up images of intrepid groups
wearing hats trekking through empty lands
in search of hidden treasures, but that was
certainly not the reality when, for instance,
Vasco De Gama reached India in 1498 and found
a highly developed Indian Ocean commerce with
trading posts run by sophisticated Muslim
merchants.
Da Gama’s instincts were to menace and fight
them and he did.
And when the Portuguese reached Southeast
Asia and China, they found a cornucopia of
goods that Europeans came to crave and about
whose production they hadn’t the slightest
knowledge: colorful, washable cottons, and
finely crafted porcelain, also tea.
Where would we be without Tea?
Well, I’d be fine, actually.
I’d just drink coffee.
What’s that?
Oh, Stan informs me that coffee also isn’t
from Europe.
By the seventeenth century, the Portuguese
were importing millions of pieces of porcelain
into Europe along with lots of delicious spices.
And spices were not only important for flavouring,
but also for food preservation.
Which I suppose is a kind of flavouring if
you like your food not-mouldy tasting.
Let’s go to the Thought Bubble.
The Portuguese “empire” was, at first
anyway, a trading empire,
with small and agile ships known as caravels
patrolling ports and collecting large fees.
The wealth would be extracted from controlling
shipping and trading routes,
as the Ottomans were doing in the eastern
Mediterranean.
In contrast, the Spanish empire, which began
in 1492 with the exploratory voyages of Genoese
ship captain Christopher Columbus,
was based on colonies--
that is, rather than controlling trade routes,
the empire would control the land itself and
the people who lived there,
and extract wealth from them to enrich the
empire.
Columbus was a student of geography and maps
and he’d lobbied the Portuguese king to
back his voyages.
But when that didn’t go to plan, he headed
for Spain to petition its devoutly Catholic
rulers,
Queen Isabella of Castile and King Ferdinand
of Aragon.
These two monarchs were finishing up the drive
to expel Muslims from Spain
and to force Spanish Jews to convert to Christianity.
But religious persecution wasn’t cheap.
The motto of the Iberian pathfinders—God,
gold, and glory—perfectly described their
ambitions.
Although perhaps not in that order.
Hopping the islands along the African coast
and using the trade winds,
Columbus’s ships made it to the Caribbean
islands,
and his crews, which tellingly included both
clergy and bankers,
found signs of gold but not great quantities
of it.
However, they did find people to enslave,
and because no one knew the size or shape
of the Americas,
there was the perpetual hope that gold or
other riches
might lie just on the other side of this river,
or that mountain.
Thanks Thought Bubble.
So I want to stop here to shift perspective:
From the perspective of European explorers,
these lands were new, and potentially very
lucrative, and the colonization model that
Spain adopted, and that Portugal began using
in Brazil, and that the rest of Europe’s
empires would eventually use, was built on
the idea that colonies existed for the benefit
and enrichment of the colonizers--and secondarily
to convert human souls to Christianity.
Much of the wealth that was generated by these
empires was done so by claiming human beings
as a form of property--both through the slave
trade and through forcing colonized people
to work.
And the systems that were built to support
the colonies--from roads and bridges to churches--were
built to extract wealth and convert people
to Christianity.
So from the perspective of indigenous people
living in colonized communities, colonization
meant impoverishment in many forms--the loss
of land for use, the loss of life itself at
an unprecedented scale, the loss of long-held
religious beliefs, and the loss of all sorts
of community assets.
But from the colonziers’ perspective, it
meant the possibility of getting rich, and
so waves of ambitious sailors followed Columbus,
searching both North and South America for
extractable wealth.
OK.
Another breakthrough occurred in 1519-22,
when Ferdinand Magellan’s Spanish ships
circumnavigated the globe.
Magellan had alienated members of the Portuguese
court and like Columbus he found no backing
for his proposed trip there.
Also like Columbus, he went to Spain to fund
his voyage.
If you were going to be somewhere between
1519 and 1522, on one of Magellan’s ships
was not necessarily the best place.The conditions
and Magellan’s no-nonsense discipline caused
mutinies and other problems which Magellan
also handled harshly, executing or marooning
mutineering captains in the fleet.
But after finding the straits at the tip of
South America, the fleet set out across the
Pacific, eventually returning to Spain despite
Magellan’s death at the hands of local leaders
in the Philippines in 1521.
Of the 237 original voyagers and five ships,
only eighteen men and one ship returned to
Spain in 1522.
But, the voyage arranged and headed by Magellan
was a revelation, it opened the world up to
global transportation, exchange, settlement,
and yes, global slavery, warfare, pandemics,
and conquest.
The Spanish could now stock their new world
settlements with Chinese and Indian luxuries
by crossing the Pacific and fill their coffers
from profits in New World goods by crossing
the Atlantic.
In 1519, Spanish invader Hernan Cortés came
in contact with indigenous people in present-day
Mexico, landing on its Mayan eastern coast
with several hundred soldiers and making his
way inland, starting battles and forging alliances.
He eventually reached the center of the Aztec
empire at Tenochtitlan, the Spaniards were
astonished at the wealth of this civilization
and Cortes bowed before its king, Montezuma
II, who led a vast empire that stretched to
present-day Honduras and Nicaragua.
The capital had tens of thousands of inhabitants,
perhaps hundreds of thousands.
Markets overflowed with luscious produce and
crafts, and the city had a sophistication
that, like the wealth itself, was foreign
to Europeans, even if the Aztec practice of
human sacrifice was also foreign.
A similar awe filled Francisco Pizarro when
he saw the superb textiles and silver and
gold objects crafted by the Incas, who’d
also created thousands of miles of roads and
efficient institutions to hold their vast
empire together along the west coast of present-day
South America.
Both Pizarro and Cortes relied on help from
rival indigenous communities to help them
take control from the Incas and Aztecs.
The conquerors also married the princesses
and other noble women they had raped as a
ritual of domination.
And marriage gave them access to insider information,
local networks, and the wealth that such women
possessed—including wealth in enslaved peoples.
So, Iberians were incentivized to set sail
by their poverty and by their Catholic faith,
but they were disadvantaged by a comparative
lack of manufacturing skills when it came
to trade.
What they did have, at least at first, was
sailing prowess and weaponry on their side.
Iberian caravels were nimble and they could
be loaded with cannons.
The Portuguese borrowed the use of triangular
sails from the Arabs, often combining them
with square-rigged ones to make better use
of the winds.
And Iberians also employed a range of navigational
instruments—technology generally taken from
other cultures—in determining latitude,
while their on-board cartographers created
portolan charts--literally, charts related
to ports--indicating coastal dangers, good
harbors, and other details important to seafarers.
Astrolabes, quadrants, compasses, and other
instruments gave good indications of location
and direction but you know what you really
needed?
A clock.
That’s right, there’s a clock in the center
of the world.
This six dollar clock is an astonishing piece
of technology.
Stan would like me to point out that it was
actually eight dollars.
Thank you for your support on Patreon.com/crashcourse
it wasn’t until the eighteenth century development
of the chronometer that sailors could chart
longitudinal location, and even now, GPS relies
on an extremely precise knowledge of the time.
In short when it comes to history and also
everything else, it’s not just a question
of where you are, it’s a question of when
you are.
Early European explorers almost always had
to enlist local people to advise them how
to navigate the seas, especially the Indian
ocean, and local, non-European traders served
as intermediaries for the artisans in porcelain,
cotton, and other crafted products.
Through them, Europeans slowly learned about
trading procedures, sources of goods, and
the means of judging quality, as initially
the Iberians were not well acquainted with
the goods available in these trading ports.
And there were other go-betweens, like translators,
connecting Europeans and local people.
One example is Malinche (or Doña Maria, as
the Spanish called her).
She facilitated the passage of Hernan Cortes
and his small army across Mexico and into
the capital of the Aztec empire, gathering
allies for him and warning him of impending
danger along the way.
Because of the hostility among different groups,
go-betweens who knew about the animosities
and warfare among them could help mobilize
support for the Europeans, so that one local
group would lead the charge against another.
That happened in the conquest of both Central
America in the 1520s and the Inca Empire in
the 1530s.
In Europe meanwhile, all of this voyaging
and conquering produced chaos between the
Iberian kingdoms--what land would be Spain’s,
and what land would be Portugal’s?
A treaty sponsored by the Church eventually
settled disputes between Spain and Portugal
over territory that each was claiming.
I mean, who do you call about property disputes,
if not the pope?
The Treaty of Tordesillas, which was signed
in 1494, provided a permanent line of demarcation
370 leagues west of the Cape Verde islands
off the Atlantic coast of Africa.
In 1529, another treaty set bounds for each
country in the Indian Ocean and Pacific regions.
But treaties of course did not prevent the
death at the hands of European weaponry and
diseases that contact entailed.
In the Western Hemisphere, the local inhabitants’
lack of resistance to European diseases was
probably a more important factor than in conquest
than weaponry was.
In the long run, violence, enslavement, and
European diseases like smallpox and measles
led to the death of perhaps as much as ninety
percent of the indigenous American population.
Diseases spread and killed so quickly that
entire communities ceased to exist almost
--- at once, and with them their traditions,
stories, and values.
Meanwhile, colonization proved extremely lucrative
for Spain and Portugal, which within a century
went from being poor kingdoms to astonishingly
rich ones, especially after 1545, when the
Spanish uncovered a huge deposit of silver
in Potosi, in present day Bolivia, and began
conscripting indigenous people to do the most
dangerous work in the mines.
Migration to both regions swelled, and ships
now criss-crossed both Atlantic and the Pacific.
And this huge influx of wealth to Spain and
Portugal would reshape power in Europe and
also life everywhere else, as everything from
microbes to ideas suddenly had a truly global
reach.
Thanks for watching.
I’ll see you next time.